new in theaters this weekend last
Christmas playing with fire and dr.
sleep what will you see this is your
weekend ticket I think you just peed in
your eye yeah I think so
in last Christmas a young woman named
Kate is down on her luck and jaded by
things in her past but a mysterious and
charming man pops into her life in the
most random places and random times
leading her to relook her outlook on
life and get back into the holiday
spirit interestingly the story and
script of last Christmas was written by
Emma Thompson who also stars in the film
well that is interesting
oh this movies for you if you're ready
to get into the holiday spirit you're
looking forward to seeing emilia clarke
star in a movie again or you already
think they should make a sequel called
last christmas - for real this time it's
the last one I promise
gentlemen we are smokejumpers the most
elite team of fire fighters in the world
we must be at our very best with fire an
elite group of firefighters successfully
rescued three children but they soon
realize they might be unsuccessful when
they are forced to babysit the kids
while they wait for their parents to
return this movie is for you of a fun
family flick is what you seek this
weekend
you love the comedic antics of John Cena
or if you like the chin of John Cena I
don't know about magic I was called at
the shining
the world is a hungry place the
dangerous place
[Music]
these people they hurt the really long
awaited sequel to The Shining doctors
sleep is based on the 2013 novel by
Stephen King in it we catch up with
Danny as he is still psychologically
haunted and damaged on top of that he
soon finds a girl who also has developed
psychic powers but an evil cult of quasi
immortals learn of their powers and
intend to capture and feed off of the
girls abilities that's mean this movie
is for you if you're in the mood for a
suspense movie this weekend you're
interested in seeing the sequel to the
original shining or you can read my mind
and write that is your weekend ticket
what will you see and check back next
week to see two angels hey you know what
make it three